also in texas the state's law banning  most abortions has been suspended  federal judge blocked it last night the  order bars enforcement of the statute  that went into effect in september the  court's order described it as a quote  scheme to deprive citizens of a  significant and well-established  constitutional right  basically what you saw the department of  justice arguing is a substance of this  law there's no way it can be squared  with our current president which is  which is roe v wade that current  president also going to be looked at by  the supreme court later this year  meantime texas is expected to appeal  this decision